BAN THE TRAMPOLINES! AND THE BICYCLES! AND
THE SCOOTERS! Cuz...who needs childhood anyway?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews. How
many ER visits would you guess resulted from
trampolines from 2002-2011? If you guessed
over ONE MILLION, then dang....you're good
at guessing. It's a number thats got at least
one group of researchers from Indiana University's
Medical School a liiiiittle concerned. Of
those 1 million injuries, almost ⅓ of them
were broken bones. Now I grew up around trampolines,
everybody seemed to have one in the 90s, and
I'll admit: there were definitely a lot of
broken bones. And really, broken things in
general. Kids elbowing each other midair and
getting bloody noses, falling through the
cracks and pulling a muscle, landing on a
broken spring and tearing their flesh open.
I mean, it's just par for the course when
it comes to trampolines.
The study, which was published in the Journal
of Pediatric Orthopaedics, found that the
trampoline injuries cost Americans 1 billion
dollars, and the scientists believe that it's
something parents should seriously think twice
about. They're not the only ones either, the
American Academy of Pediatrics has recommended
against trampolines for 15 years.
So, the question remains...should we do away
with trampolines? One way to answer that question
would be to look at how trampoline injuries
measure up to other recreational activities,
like say...skateboarding or cycling. Bicycles
alone are responsible for over 250,000 children's
injuries every year. But, bicycles are also
much more common than trampolines....so while
the exact numbers don't exist, I'm gonna guess
that trampoline for trampoline and bike for
bike, trampolines are probably still more
dangerous. Another important thing to consider
is that trampoline injuries have definitely
fallen in recent years since the glorious
invention of safety nets came along -- the
injury rates fell from about 110,000 a year
to 80,000 a year. But the doctors say LOOK,
THESE INJURIES ARE PREVENTABLE. And 80,000
is still too many.
I gotta admit: they have a point. But I just
had SO MUCH FUN on trampolines as a kid. Good
times, good exercise...but the responsible
adult in me acknowledges that they can be
kind of dangerous. Especially when they're
not properly maintained or when a bunch of
kids are bouncing around on them without supervision.
Just between you and me, I probably wouldn't
mind getting one for my kid, so long as it
has a safety net. OK so they break few bones...fracture
their spine....it'll be good for em! Toughen
em up a bit.
Thanks for joining me for DNews folks: what
do you think? Is the trampoline our friend
or a foe? Let me know down below and we'll
see you next time.